so have you seen that Bobby Lee has been
being canceled on Tick Tock yeah for
something I [__] we covered and I
covered on night wave [__] three
years ago well did you see his
explanation
that it was all [__] bit all right I
want to start off this podcast a little
differently guys okay what's happening
I'm gonna [__] a kid and I have to you
know
I was gonna say that's differently Bobby
Lee right there's the podcast version
but I have to put on the real Bobby Lee
version on for just this first segment
if you guys don't mind I don't mind
there is no difference you're pretending
that this is a character you play when
this is really you you're such a [__]
liar right off the bat he's lying okay
so I want to address this uh yeah this
is literally the thing me and Royce do
is has been doing is a bit since the
beginning of this show yeah like every
time we say something edgy or something
we make up a name we're like oh there's
something after that okay Bobby
Tijuana
story
there's a Tijuana story that I've seen
you act I've seen try to act Bobby
you're not a good actor you weren't
acting hold on open Anthony don't do
this
don't do that I told um many many how
was I supposed to know you were acting
Bobby you didn't say uh oh hot dog
during the story yeah you didn't go
sometimes I do so
oh
and yep um
you know there's been an uptick you know
and an uproar about this story and I've
always wanted to talk about it but
the people around me are like you know
what you didn't do anything it'll die
down but I'm always like yeah but I can
explain it this is all sociopathic lying
this is sociopathic lying you're lying
Bobby
no one's buying this right like no you
don't no I when I covered this years ago
um I I played the whole O A Clip and
it's dude it it's not he wasn't doing a
bit man and if he was doing a bit I
don't know what the bit was you know
what I mean yeah but that's what I mean
there was no payoff it wasn't like it
was a funny punch line to it
you should because if you know
you don't want to folk you want people
to focus on it
and
you know Mickey brusco's do I Like
Comics ever do like comedy
no
it's very funny this last question I
like that Bobby's just like you know and
everybody's like all focused on I hate
when everybody's all focused on the fact
that I took advantage of a sex
trafficked child yeah why are you guys
making such a big deal guys I want to
focus on Comedy yeah it's been so bad I
just I just need to say something yeah
were you also the one that did so let me
guess kalila [__] jerking off a dog
that was a bit and her [__] two
brothers that's all about it everything
you did that we've made video about this
a bit now right you know and I'm not you
know I mean I think I mean it's easily
explainable and um so let's start from
the Genesis of the beginning
the Genesis is the beginning
oh you're right yeah yeah so can I just
say Genesis at the beginning
thank you yeah
so many years ago um I had to go to New
York and play this club called Carolines
it's world famous John why are you
smiling and um
not the time not the time shot are you
high oh my God
bro weed bro
high level of shock and I was just like
you know what yeah you ate like bull
testing yeah I know absurdity it's
absurd right it was delicious by the way
so you know at the time I had two jokes
in my act right yeah the first show and
they would only work maybe 40 30 of the
time the first joke was oh it's not as
bad it's like you know I went on a date
the other day she seemed pretty young
she looked like Natalie Portman pause
from the movie professional right wow
it's a switch Yeah that's what that kind
of joke is yeah that's a switch bro it's
explaining the craft
dark the second one wait for the second
one it's way worse
it's way worse to suck one
the other joke that I could only get
work 20 of the time was my girlfriend's
grandma died a couple of weeks ago
and last night we were making love and
she burst into tears while we were
making love
and I did what any good boyfriend would
do
I power [__] her
yeah twenty percent yeah and how was
that worse at least that one was an
adult but also
what's the joke this La comedy scene
I mean I'm trying I mean like it's like
Bro [__] off you're gonna tell me you
you've gone to Thailand you've [__]
hookers you've talked about [__]
underage hooker so what's a lie just the
underage part but you did [__] hookers
or you didn't [__] hookers at all what
is it yeah because that's not part then
that's not true then the part about the
joke about Natalie Portman's not true
it's not thank you tell the kid you
[__] yeah exactly
it's a harsh joke it's [__] terrible
and I took the team the [__]
um Natalie Portman joke that joke I made
up this Tijuana you know what I mean
story wait wait wait a second you added
30 Black Marines too no no no no I'm
gonna get to that I've heard about this
right right so so then
um but in my mind I'm like no one ever
talks about the second half of the story
the crazy part the crazy part they focus
on the now the child [__]
yeah they always focus on that that
annoying [__] nagging part about the
[__] kids play Portland whatever it's
terrible it's awful okay
but the second half is so crazy and you
know easily like you know
it didn't it's it's obvious it didn't
happen so it's not that obvious let's
just give you the the run through of
what the second half of the story is is
I go back to tier one a week later
a Mexican guy
who's
albino
no no here's what you're doing it's not
that you've told this joke just here
you've told jokes in the similar quote
unquote recently on your podcast about
going to Thailand and saying these women
are of age remember we played that so be
one thing if you're like oh it's back in
the day for a bit for Ona but you kind
of have a pattern of the same thing and
these aren't bits you're not selling
them as bits and he's always been openly
like a sex degenerate yeah he's
pretending like everything he said
ever do is a bit
everything
stories between they're all lies
or only the stuff that's bad later is a
lie I'm trying to figure that out
dwarf with freckles on his face I'm
stronger and there's a bunch of origin
stories I do too right you have 10. yeah
so it's like I remember my brother going
one time we were like driving to
Koreatown and he goes you were never
molestified go without Senator Michael I
know you know what I mean oops you know
okay so what he's doing is he's
explaining either that he's a liar
because he's acting like everything when
he jokes about something all the time
he's joking about something
Bobby's trying to sell himself like he's
always been the guy who lies like he's
always been the guy who lies and doesn't
but he's not that's not your character
Bobby
so what you're saying is either you you
make up these stories pretend that
they're real to get attention or these
things are really happening to you and
now you're going like holy [__] that
makes me look bad I'm gonna say I was
kidding right yeah because he's probably
getting I know he's getting some
blowback from this yeah and again so
then the next question is that this
whole show you could break it down did
khalila jerk off a dog was that a bit
she [__] her brothers
that's what I want to know I love
[__] dogs
[__] dogs is very much cultural
appropriation
give me a time stamp version I don't
know the time stamp I'm sorry Bob
I'm sure it's coming up hey you know who
would have had the timestamps uh uh
merch the great produce the great
producers over at Infowars oh yeah not
only will they have found the clip it
would have been ready and rocking or
honestly just the other great producers
here yeah come over and we have like
sweet dinners they are better all of
these things and like I I know who you
are there isn't I can firmly say there
are a few people that know you better
than me I told this story because I was
like I have nothing in the here you go I
said this story 10 years ago on
tigerbelly I completely left out the
Natalie Portman thing right because you
just kind of just say it you don't
remember how it really because I thought
the point I thought the only point
of the story was to deliver the Natalie
Portman joke yeah and the power [__]
thing which I still don't understand
does it in the context of a joke
so
if you're telling a story and the story
Soul point is to set up a joke and now
you're telling the story without the
punch line I feel like it's a real story
but you know the bullet points and you
just kind of make [__] up again you
think Natalie Portman will do tigerbelly
I would love to you should yeah yeah we
have a cat knocking on the door I'll say
this I know that feeling not to your
extent because you've been in you know
um famous for a long time but you're a
sociopathic [__] and you have to make
it about yourself kalilah yes your turn
you're the floor psychopath sorry but
like like I was on JK news once and I
was under slept and I told a story I
thought it was funny I told this story
because I was like I have nothing in the
tank I have nothing in the tank and I do
like in what what entered my brain was a
memory of like my much older cousin yeah
telling me to jerk off my German
Shepherd I remember that yeah and I was
like seven years oh I was like seven
years old right and he was like how old
are you when you [__] your brothers
um well there he is you have to make him
happy yeah and because he's like humping
everything and I was like how do I make
him happy and he's like you just do this
and it ended up like touching like at
seven years old like thinking that I had
to release my German Shepherds from his
like you know like yeah
I mean the Germans
like this reputation that I would ever
do this it's bad for your brand it's bad
for my brand you [__] your [__]
brother you [__] [__]
or let me guess was that a bit too
and jerked off a dog
to be fair there's no just it's first
off Bobby's a lying but on top of that
[__] even with a terrible story about
potentially being a pedophile
has to [__] still make it about
herself why would you want to interject
yourself in this story I would be like
sitting there quietly like I'm not
getting him you know what I mean like oh
I'm not you know I'm not gonna be part
of your [__] you [__] Beetle story
but instead hold on first hold on don't
hear me out but instead she goes wait a
second it's not about me for a second
yeah you might be a pedo but I jerked
off a dog
yeah I would be doing the opposite like
wow you [__] what that's way worse
than [__] a dog anybody that [__] a
dog would be like a way better person
than like you that [__] a child that's
for [__]
what are you doing man
but you know but but you know what but
what but this whole thing though has
um like I'm no longer on social media
anymore yeah I wouldn't be either if you
said you [__] somebody that looked
like that I mean honestly if I came out
multiple times told a story in Vivid
detail we're calling how I [__] a
child sex slave I would probably you
know there'd be a little bit of a
Twitter cooldown time for me
and I may never go back you know what
and I'm so much happier about it I just
why
I mean I I feel just so I'm like just
doing other things and I'm not scrolling
and I'm not you know I mean it's it's I
think you know in many yeah but did
social media give you like
like I don't think that people should
drive you away from it if at one point
social no of course you don't because if
you leave social media then you will
have no intention and because you're not
just an attention but a regular [__]
you have to have it all the time even if
it means degrading people around you
potential friends even enemies doesn't
matter because it's all about you kalila
I have never [__] I am astonished I'm
always astonished and I mean this from
the bottom of my heart I am astonished
that I could watch a video that's
supposed to be about Bobby Lee defending
whether or not he [__] a child and
kalila can still be the worst part of
that video it really blows my mind that
you could do that I mean that is some
[__] magic that is some that is some
Jordan Flu Game [__] to come into this
video and still be the worst part about
a child [__] video that's not about
you how do you do that kalila I have to
know is it some sort of half Filipino
magic I Wanna Know
holy [__]
it is it's astonishes me that she's that
horrible of a person I she is definitely
in our Hall of Fame probably one of the
worst people yeah I've ever ever seen
and and that's saying something because
you know her boyfriend probably [__]
the kid
the media posting about your life but
she almost jerked off a puppy made you
happy you should reclaim that yeah but
um I don't know this time around
the comments were so brutal because they
think you [__] a child and you've
never cleared it up I can't believe that
you it's not like they're going like oh
ching chong China man you ching chong
ching ching ching chong okay that's
pretty funny yeah oh that is funny but
they're [__] saying stuff because
they think you it's like you know it's
like the Louis C.K joke it's like yeah
maybe pro-livers are mad because they
think you're literally murdering a baby
maybe these people are mad because they
think you actually [__] a kid you
think about that just for a second Bobby
then maybe that's why these comments how
are you the victim here I would argue
the victim is somewhere in Tijuana
you know what I mean that the victim's
probably already like 30 years old or
has had all their limbs dropped off and
or both stuck in a burning tire
[Music]
your mom and your whole family should
kill yourself yeah you know what I mean
um you know I mean you should stick a
shock under your mouth and blow your
head off and when you read stuff like
that you just kind of go you know I mean
like basically I just been going to a
meetings and just like just you're not
the victim here Bobby
he blew past the kid [__] story he
just blew past it well this is the new
but this is the new blueprint I mean
this is what everybody does and now
you're the victim Bobby these people and
US included and we're not [__]
retards Bobby that this call this the
tale of Lorenz by the way Bobby this
this this little [__] game you're
playing I work with a bunch of stupid
normies we've been doing this too
[__] long okay we've seen people like
you we've seen these explanations Time
After Time After Time all the time
and you're doing the same Playbook
you're you are sitting here saying it's
just a joke I'm just joking if it was a
joke the very first time you heard that
accusation you go look guys I was
[__] around on a show I don't know
what you're talking about but you didn't
you let it build and you let it build
until it became insurmountable and then
it became like I better explain myself
here's the issue Bobby you did this to
yourself you're not a victim listen I
don't know whether you did it or not
Bobby only you would know and maybe you
were joking maybe you're a fibber maybe
you are and that's probably the best
case scenario here if you're a liar but
if you're not and everybody thought you
were telling the truth except for you're
seeing three people around you because
even when you listen to him saying oh
and hey everyone know when they thought
he was telling the truth too they didn't
think he was joking you know
[__] Anthony was writing down the
address
so
I'm just saying uh
so anyway so my point is is that do not
[__] play this game with us Bobby
this this might work a stupid little
Normie Twitter retards people [__]
work with us all right so either say it
was a joke [__] I should have done
that I'm a [__] idiot for not
clearing it up I get why people are mad
at me but the one thing you shouldn't do
is try to play the victim
Ula Comics have been [__] you've been
in therapy so long that they fried any
[__] human circuits in your brain
you're basically just a bunch of
catchphrases that you would see in a
white girl's house that's what you are
you're the you're the Instagram feed of
a [__] white spinster that's all your
talking points she was even saying the
LA comic talk oh no you should tell your
truth oh don't let anyone silence you
okay you know you should live your life
you guys you shouldn't sometimes you
should shut your mouth sometimes your
truth is stupid and if more people told
you your truth is stupid you'd probably
[__] less kids
sorry
or at least not get so comfortable that
you just openly tell your kid [__]
stories no you know it's like that's how
chill you are with your kid [__] yeah
these dude that's what happened this is
what an age of Tolerance and nobody
having any shame brought us
it's like just
you're supposed to like ah it's okay man
you know that's like you said your truth
man
I'm sorry but it's it's he's doing he's
playing right at a tale of lorenza's
[__] Playbook it's you know do
something obnoxious when people come
after me I'm like wow I'm a victim I've
had to go into hiding to [__] up man
you're not the victim here okay
Bobby Bobby
you know I mean trying to meditate and
this and that but it's like it was
pretty brutal and um you know I was just
burst into tears driving down the street
it's called regret
it was [__] terrible
and I just don't know if I want to go
back you know he's crying like [__]
Patrick Swayze at the end of Donnie
Darko
um and I'm gonna take a that's a good
reference everyone think about it right
I I know I just it was a very good
reference I just spent so long since I
never liked that movie I I don't I was
always one of those that didn't get it
well at the end of the movie for those
who don't know Donnie Darko he was he
had he was filming child porn in his
basement and he was breaking down
because he remembered it vacation on my
own I've never done that in my life
like you know like Ari did that did you
yeah yeah man he would be in Thailand or
I mean great wall with his backpack you
know man yeah running from the Kobe
thing you know
I don't can you at least Bobby can you
at least be funny
or at least all right hear me out on
this race please maybe just during this
segment where you're talking about the
12 year old you allegedly raped um don't
don't maybe be less tone deaf
you know like if you're not gonna be
funny then don't laugh like a morning
zoo show because now you're not being
funny and also being tone deaf
you know yeah but even even you know
like even like my friends that have said
crazy things and this and that it's like
you know the internet's fickle it it
dies down you know and um you know you
know I because when Ari did the Kobe
thing I was like oh he's gone do not
compare all Ari telling a joke about
[__] Kobe which is 100 legal and then
people going after him because they
couldn't take a [__] joke to people
getting mad because they believed you're
[__] a kid story those things are not
the same stop stop don't you love when
people do that when they go hey me and
you we're this it's like looking in a
freaking mirror no it's not sir Cut From
the Same Cloth no it is [__] not all
right if we're done with this we we had
the point I do believe it's a real story
though because it's I've heard the story
told Ono and a and I've played it before
and it's me too it's not fun it's not a
fun story